hey everybody and welcome back to the
36th ever
iced coffee hour where the channel has
already made thirty four thousand seven
hundred fourteen dollars
i'm grant nevar and i am very happy to
be here that was my
intro that was amazing that's gotta go
into highlights
yeah perfect well thank you so much for
coming on the channel
so you've come quite a ways all the way
to las vegas
and for those that don't know you you've
been on the gram stefan show before
i interviewed you because you reached an
11 million dollar real estate
portfolio with 31 rental properties
bringing in 50
000 a month you build them you sell them
and now you're selling them
uh and you have quite an interesting
story of running a car dealership
uh smoothie place too you make smoothies
we have smoothie madness to talk about
here
really interesting and you also brought
some
team rocket pokemon cards to it's
unopened here's
six packs for us to each open up two
packs
of pokemon cards and to keep you guys
watching i'm also
going to unpack is it what do we call
unpack um
it's opening the box we're going to be
opening up this base pack
that i bought a few months ago this is a
thousand dollars so this
little thing right here that's crazy who
knows what's inside of it but
uh guys all you got to do is smash the
like button for the youtube algorithm
and we could pull a charizard we could
pull a charizard here in a dark
charizard over there hollow
so if you pull it just just in case do
you know the value of that charizard if
you get a psa 10 uh
well it's not shadowless so it's a it's
going to have a shadow i'm going to
guess a psa 10
shadow maybe three grand four or five
grand i thought the same thing
yeah when i pulled some on the steve
aoki pack pools right
and when you pull them up on last sold
twenty thousand bucks
yeah why thousand dollars and that's a
that's a base set
up yeah yeah geez yes they 10. yeah if
you get a nine it's like 1900 bucks
wow so really quick tell me how many
packs have you purchased from steve aoki
and how much are those
so uh a good friend of mine
runs his stuff and he's been messaging
me for him um
i probably probably purchased ten ten
ten packs from steve
and you get the very beginning was one
and one like you purchased one you'd get
another pack
then he started doing like you would get
so that 10 includes
he started doing like a base set with a
rocket and a base set
with it so how much was that uh he made
the pricing uh the year
two thousand and twenty one dollars
that's what he did so it was four four
thousand bucks but
i pulled two charizards and uh so you
got your money back
did you yeah you did so if if the first
one's a nine
and the second one's a ten then that's
still twenty something a thousand bucks
did you send them in to get graded then
not yet not yet okay they're so backed
up i thought about grading some cards
too but they're so backed up you can
expedite them but they're like 500
a card like you really got to make it
worth it so i'm gonna wait for them to
open up
and then walk them in and that i think
is generally the smartest thing to do is
you gotta go with them in person
give it to them pay a premium get it
back the same day guys we should know
this is the
first podcast episode we are filming in
vegas
yes there we go that's huge this is yeah
this is well you're the first one to
film a podcast
yeah this is where it's gonna be really
uh unless we have a guest in la but for
the most part is they're gonna be here
now you know
you're actually gonna see this setting
before graham's main channel sees it
wow because he's releasing a video soon
that shows
all the interior and everything after
it's been done yeah but that's coming
later yep
so guys just to give a little bit of a
background who grant is and
how we met he was actually a part of the
mentorship group
link down below you're getting better at
the plugs
down below yeah
but yeah he was a part of the mentorship
group and uh i just remember like when
we would meet in the zoom calls
him and i ended up talking a lot and we
got to know each other i took down his
phone number
and we we started talking a lot and you
started befriending graham and stuff
and then we uh we plan to do a video
like this uh a big old pokemon card
unboxing what i what i found was amazing
that uh we did a phone call on the
graham stefan show
about what five six months ago and then
when i hit 2 million subscribers you
sent me this rolex
which was insane got this this box in
the mail
it's like what is this opened it up and
it it's engraved
2 million subscribers on the back yeah
that's pretty incredible i wear this all
the time you see this rolex
yeah graham loves that yeah you see me
wearing this and i'd say a third of my
videos i'm wearing it and
everyone's like graham you're wearing a
rolex you're so excited i'm like
grant got me the one it's okay it's okay
guys but yeah i love it
if i don't if you don't mind stay tuned
for this whole video because if you like
the rolex that i got graham that might
not be as crazy as a rolex
but it still might be your first i don't
know so it's another question i am
i'm so curious to see what this might be
anyway so you have a surprise for graham
yeah and i have a surprise for you too
but i'll tell you that when we do the
pattern you got a surprise too
wow and look i do this just because
i appreciate them too right we've like
they said we're friends
so this is fun you'll get my real
reaction i have no idea yeah no idea
there have been a lot of events in this
relationship developing and it's been a
fun time it's been a long time
and uh this is actually our first day
meeting grant
yeah it's also really exciting though
yeah no it's weird because we've talked
online for like a year
before meeting but it's it's one of
those things that when you've been
talking so much
or just doing like zoom calls back and
forth on the mentorship group down below
in the description
uh like when we met it was like just
we're friends like we already know each
other
there's no like yeah awkwardness is like
hey i'm graham
i'm grants nothing like that it's just
fun and after this
we're also going to go gambling a little
bit oh jack has really wanted to do this
what are you putting me down for no no
that's your idea graham really wants to
gamble so i said fine graham if you
really
get on your knees and beg yeah we'll go
and gamble so we're gonna go gambling
and we'll show you guys the results at
the end of the podcast episode there
will be a little segment of us talking
about our experience gambling so stay
tuned for that and this
i would like to say this house is
absolutely beautiful thank you thank you
so much thank you
including jackson well i'm sure it's
nowhere near so you're building some
real estate but let's
let's go back a minute how did you get
started in real estate
uh so when i was 18 years old uh started
selling cars
and what ended up happening is i did
really well right so
my average for all those years were
about 75 000
a year and uh how i got started and i
said this
i don't know if it would make it to the
grim stefan show
but my mother told me that i couldn't
have girls in my room and
i decided that i had to have a place of
my own and so that's how it started 18
years old i
got a loan and you know bought an
apartment that was half of a duplex for
96 000 bucks now i know graham advocates
for living with the family but in a
situation like this graham what would
you say
to the mother or to grant you you got to
look at the financial value of being
able to have a girl over at the house
is that really worth no two thousand
dollars a month
i would i would advocate probably not
unless maybe not to you graham but to
someone
like grant how much would you pay 10
girls over at the house jack
well considering
no that's not true let's cut that part
out um
we're not going to cut that out i look
at the financial value of that i'm like
okay
i get saved let's say how much were you
saving living at home
so my mortgage is only 55 bucks
yeah you're from a different place
though you're not from california 96 000
is what i what it cost me okay and it
was it was it was an apartment it was
half of a duplex
that's not costing you so the
opportunity cost of putting your money
in there versus living at home it's
really
not that big because you could have
instead bought a rental property rented
it out
i did that the next year you did that
the next year but it also costs to get
that hot tub i had to put in the in the
backyard that was fun you got a hot tub
i did
so you really wanted girls over that was
that was the reason why you moved out
this is turning into a girl topic i love
my beautiful fiance caleb zena so yeah
of course
so yes thankfully my mom would let her
be in the room
at that 31. is this is this what started
you off in investing he's like i want to
have girls over
so like i got to get my own place that's
an origin story right there
it is but that is the main like i'm very
honest and that is the very
reason why i did it and then at 19 i
realized that uh
i could build two a whole duplex for not
double the price that i paid for that
one so i built my first duplex for right
around 140 000 bucks
and then i lived in one side rented the
other side and i stayed there for
a very long and how do you just like
build a duplex coming from no background
in real estate or did you have a
background
so i was very fortunate my i do come
from a very good family my brother uh
barrett
uh who is part of my core principles
i've watched others and i've watched
their successful failures i'm very
fortunate to have those people around me
but what happened was he built them
uh i bought i actually bought the
apartment from him
is where i got the the very good deal
then he sold the next one for 80
you know so i didn't get the best deal
oh my god he sold it to you at a premium
yeah
you know what are you doing you've got
to charge a little bit more for fans
okay so but anyway he built it so i kind
of watched it i like to watch and absorb
and then and then do
so i just trial and error after that i
mean he didn't give me any pointers
didn't tell me anything i just
went out and built a duplex and i made
mistakes but
all in all it worked out great so you're
selling cars what made you sell cars
why cars so uh it's just my family so
they've always been in the car business
and that's that's what i did as well
so yeah that seems pretty impressive
that you built a duplex at 19 though
because i'm 22 and i can't even like
fathom you can't even put up a hang a
picture no i can't
no yeah i can't even hang tv so that's
that's that's my impressive uh
able to fix things things that's
impressive it is
but first a word from our sponsor
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community for creatives where
millions come together to take the next
step in their creative journey for
example a skillshare class i'm looking
to take is ali abdull's video editing
with final cut pro 10 from beginner to
youtuber i love ally's video editing
skills and i just love his style and i
know for a fact if i take that class i'm
gonna get some great insight on how i
can up my editing game now i know video
editing is may just be for me
if you guys aren't interested in that
don't worry skillshare offers thousands
of inspiring classes for creative and
curious people on topics including
illustration design photography video
freelancing and more and even if you
don't have anything specific in mind
that you'd like to learn about
i strongly encourage you to check it out
anyways because maybe you'll go and
you'll check their categories and stuff
and you'll find something that you're
that'll interest you
and i think it's important to
continuously be learning new things and
trying out new things and
there's definitely not a better place to
do that than skillshare explore your
creativity at skillshare.com
iced coffee where our listeners can get
a free trial of premium membership at
skillshare.com
iced coffee thank you for watching and
back to the podcast so you were doing
pretty well then
selling cars were you just a good
salesman were you a good talker
how do you sell a car well i was also
going to college which i did not finish
uh i was a junior for a very long time
and
what ended up happening is i just
decided to focus more on that but i sold
cars for four and a half years
i was always in the top uh being a young
person going to school i actually talked
to a few people that do that now
and the car business is one of the
absolute best businesses aside from real
estate
that both of us have found our footing
in so that's that's just it built from
there but what made you so good
selling cars i've always been a people
person i'm i'm
you know just just from all three of us
your voice is amazing you have a great
voice
you have a really really good voice oh
yeah it fills yeah this room is massive
you know what it is
it's friendly it's a friendly welcoming
voice you say y'all you say yeah
sir i i listen you kept calling me sir
i'm like i'm i'm not a sir
like like this is too public this is too
polite yeah
like this is too good yeah but and i
very much thank you
it's too respectful yeah too respectful
you know call me dude
yeah what's up man we're getting towards
bro
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but but
yeah that that
would be one thing and then plus i work
like no other i you know you talk about
your work ethic and i see it in
all the videos and all the channels and
then dude you coming in see i did it
dude right there i did it we're getting
comfortable nice
and and so anyway that happened and i
watch you
do all the things you do so just long
story short i would make sure that
i did what most don't follow up keep
going and it just it
you put enough effort time and you know
consistency in anything
you're going to get results you just got
to make sure you get them long enough
where do you get the work ethic from
so that just my family watching my
father watching my brothers uh
just my own personality as well you know
i know you're you're not born with these
kinds of things but
i've always been very very competitive
so you gotta have a pretty big work
ethic to do what you do
because you you have all of your
investments spread around
like you you're actively investing in
like the smoothie place you've got your
car dealership you gotta run yeah you've
got all these
apartment complexes that you're building
up like all that has to take a lot of
time
and i don't have a property manager yeah
i do run them all we need some we need
some clickbait for the title
do you do you know like a gross number
here of like how much this all brings
every month between like the car
business between
smoothies between real estate between
investments to you
wait so do you want pre-tax gross so uh
with everything fully rented we'll just
go that number but with everything fully
rented 600 000 from the rentals
uh my smoothie business last year even
with everything that has happened
uh brought in right at 100. actually a
little bit more
but but let's just use 100 and then i
make 300 at the store
as far as you know being the director of
the 11 stores and
um so you know that's pretty close to a
million
how on earth do you manage all of that
how do you run a smoothie business
so main squeeze is pretty cool um and so
basically they make healthy easier it's
really cool and
it's a fun concept so they started in
lake charles louisiana my cousin
actually developed it
you know i hadn't seen him in forever he
comes and talks to me about it i got
excited about i've never
i've never just talked to somebody and
did it besides like something like this
sure you know
and uh anyway he did it i bought in and
i bought eight locations one's built and
the shopping center that i'm talking
about
is that we're that we're doing next
month which is very exciting
is going to be where the second one is
so you're buying a shopping center as
well
four years and that is included in the
11 million so that is that is sure
that's why i said the 11 million as in
your total you're totally out
of value and a lot of this guys we've
already discussed on the second channel
we did like a pokemon card pack unboxing
yeah go and check that out if you want
to see the other 30 packs
that we unpacked we opened them up go
and check that out that's going to be it
that's an intense video jack you're
putting a lot of time into editing that
video
yeah that's it that's just like you have
cameras guys we had five cameras
what we did is a pokemon uh battle
between both of us you had a pack i had
a pack we opened them up and we saw at
the very end who has the most value
from that uh so for your real estate now
you have 31
different properties how did you start
scaling up after the duplex
so very much like you when you make
a certain amount of income sometimes
that's blinding you know now you
kept investing and me there was a time
period
uh where i didn't so from 19 until i was
24 i didn't invest in real estate i just
had the duplex i lived in one side
i did build a house built a house i was
making 350
a year which is great income but what
ended up happening
is at 25 i built my first five plex
and after that i realized i could do
more and i knew i could do more and i
could handle more
and that's when we started really
getting into it so of course the reason
to get the capital my job
building up that income living very very
frugally and and just pushing it more
and more
every year to see what i could do so you
think having a strong income is one of
the
the best ways into getting into real
estate yes
so of course you want to make more
income you want to push yourself get a
side hustle get a lawn mower you know
you can do anything you put your mind to
as long as you put that effort and time
and commitment into it yeah
how do you manage your time between
everything what takes up the most amount
of time i feel like
probably the smoothie and the car
business probably take up the bulk of
your time the real estate's more passive
car business definitely uh real estate
you know when i get off of work i don't
get off work and of course i have my
channel too so that does take effort and
time
uh as far as my day just how to manage
myself
kayla my fiance is also my assistant and
my real estate agent so we're just it's
like one
big hub if we just you know she'll tell
me what i got to do i go do it
and then like when i have a rental i go
post it on all the pages i'll go do that
she helps tremendously and she'll fill
the calls
so that i'll i'll message them out and
if they directly message me i'll answer
them but this is her number
and i collect all the rent like it's it
the answer is i don't know i just keep
going
you know i don't think about oh i got a
lot to do i just do it and is this
sustainable how much free time
do you have like what's your work like
like on how many hours do you work every
week
if if you asked me my hobby as far as
it's sustainable
it's work i like it i like to work but
as far as how many hours a week i work
there's once 160 in the week so you know
85 to i don't have 100's realistic but
it's a lot
cause even when you go and film until
two in the morning that's still working
right in my opinion i mean definitely it
is your killing yeah
it is i feel the same way for me it's
like people ask me what do you do for
fun i'm like i work
i have fun with that and they look at me
like they're like what
that's that's fun and it is it is i have
so much fun doing it
so that's that's my that's my hobby
that's what i do for fun and if this is
technically work i'm also having a lot
of fun right
see grant what would you tell a young
excited um maybe he doesn't have a ton
of money
a 22 year old random 22 year old um no
one specifically
but just a semi-handsome 22 year old how
would they get into real estate like
what would you
what would you tell to them uh i would
tell you to
save everything just kind of like how
your attitude was earlier when i said
about gambling
and you're like i'm gonna put five
dollars on the table if you get
wanted me to put in a lot of money you
two i don't want to put in anything
i didn't want to gamble but yeah i would
say save everything same mindset that
you have
um elevate your income you know as
you've been doing you know with with
helping grant more and more
and like the iced coffee hour i mean you
know y'all are killing it with this and
it's already
100 000 subscribers almost we're so
close we're gonna hit a hundred and by
the time
maybe in a week and that's yeah that's
awesome it's very awesome for especially
for uh channels like mine
so subscribe to grant guys he's in the
description
you know but but thank you for the plug
you know but anyway so i would just say
keep saving your money keep doing that
keep going
don't you also have to start yeah
biggest thing if he would have never
started if i would have never started
you would still be 31 years old and so i
will throw this thing back out there
barrett my brother who who sold me the
apartment for 96 thousand bucks and the
next one for 80.
not upset but what ended up happening is
at 23 years old
he got overwhelmed he did it at 21 right
he started selling cars that's where i
went and so at 21 he built him at 23 got
over one that he sold him
and he has not gotten back into real
estate until this year and he's building
a shopping center now he was a general
manager just like i am making really
good income and it makes you comfortable
yeah
you know so always stay hungry keep
going and keep pushing so what did you
want to be when you grew up
did you have an idea of like i want to
be this i want to be a real i want to
run smoothie shops definitely not
smoothie shops that one came out of left
field for yeah
i would say i've always wanted to be in
sales you know you ever hurt
comment below and i don't want me to be
trying to take over the comment section
but comment below if you've ever been
told you should be a salesperson
like that's when i was a little kid
and they would recruit me to go sell the
raffle tickets
i would come back and just and i'm not
the best at numbers and things like that
i
mean
i know my numbers but it's just
sometimes not the strong point
i would come and pull out like all the
raffle money and like here you go
and they would like here's more tickets
and that they would sick them boy and
that's what i would go do
just like a good hunting dog i would
come back and that's just how i've
always been
well so i'll throw this out there too
when i was 16 and 17 years old i got
recruited to do advocare
so it's a multi-level market company but
really quick we have a word from our
sponsor nordvpn
if you're looking to improve your cyber
security look no further because nordvpn
is here nordvpn provides a virtual
private network service that basically
will just increase your internet safety
when you're browsing online i've said it
a million times before and i'll say it
again you can never be too safe when
you're browsing online
nordvpn understands that and that's why
they provide over 5500 super fast
servers in 60 countries there's no
data logging they have 24 7 support and
you can also have up to six simultaneous
connections per account i just know for
me that i like to take this safety
precaution because
i don't really know what's out there and
for me it just makes sense to be more
safe than less safe so guys if any of
this interests you and you want safer
internet browsing be sure to check out
nordvpn.com
ich you should also just use code ich
during checkout to get
the two-year plan plus one additional
month with a huge discount be sure to
get that huge discount and check out
nordvpn.com
ich or just remember to use codeich at
checkout
to get the discount thank you so much
nordvpn for supporting this episode and
back to the podcast
i was i should have brought it i'll send
you a photo if you want to use it
but i uh got a three thousand dollar
check for being the top at 18
at 17 i'm sorry and it was a 3 000 check
in 2008 for being the third highest
you know sales person in the whole
company and for the new people so not
like not the people making with the
planes you know yeah
but i thought that was cool and i was
hooked so you've always just been good
at
sales always good with people just
naturally
grew up like that i i tell you this uh a
lot of people
think this is crazy when i was doing
advocare like let's say we all went to
high school together i know you're
younger than me
right we're close to the same age i'm
not like 40. uh i'm 31.
but what would happen is i had so let's
say he went to a school and he went to a
school i would have a
sales meeting and i didn't know what
they were i would have a sales meeting
like the wolf of wall street except
without
the craziness and i would like take cash
and like let's say you made 300
commissions on those i was like jack got
300 and everybody's like
super hyped because you're high school
you get 300 bucks it's crazy
so yeah yeah i'm getting hyped about
like let's see
so what were your biggest struggles
would you say
time uh mental focus you know because
regardless of if you're a salesperson or
making
you know an hourly wage you have to keep
that mental focus because if not
you'll destroy yourself so that's always
been the struggle it's the struggle
today
you know like let's go to vegas and when
we come when we go back we're going
straight to my smoothie shop in houston
spending two days there and then we're
going back home to catch back up on
everything we left off there so
have you ever had any big financial
losses
it seems like everything you've done so
far has made my what's what's the
biggest financial loss
so when i was 18 years old uh we were on
a family vacation
and like i said i i come from a family
that's very competitive
and my brother i walked downstairs we
rented a house
and it was the last time our family ever
stayed together and my father died
pretty recently and twenty pretty
recently 2016 but yeah so it just you
know it was cool and we're all there
and my brother's yelling at the tv it's
2008 right and
a great recession was starting or or
getting ready to get bad
and so um he's yelling tv asked what are
you doing he's
he's 48 and i'm 31 so 17 year old gap
and he said i'm trading stocks at least
i heard at least he told me something so
i went away
about my business uh then we went to the
pool and my other brother was yelling at
his phone
i was like hey what are you doing he's
like he told me a little bit more
and he told me i'm trading bank of
america when the market goes
uh down i'll buy it and then when the
market goes up i sell it and then i'm
also buying
spx unit that is not a stock tip because
let me explain this story
i knew two stocks so from 18 years old
he tells me this i'm like okay he's like
i made 600 bucks today i get super
pumped and remember i was making good
income making 75 000 bucks so i said
i had 10 000 saved at this time because
i hadn't fully made
75 000 yet and i literally
run to my room and i go invest three
thousand dollars in e-trade
and i'm a creature of habit i still have
any trade account and i
did that from this day and i uh went and
invested a total
of seven thousand bucks because when you
invest three you have to wait till the
money actually clears so i'm super
excited
like ready to trade and do something and
then i had to wait like three days for
it to work so i learned as much as i
could in three days
and i traded two stocks put seven
thousand dollars in
and i rose that money to 45 grand by the
time i was 19.
wow the story is great right there
but it gets way worse and and now the
the guy what was his name i'm so sorry
i watched the entire podcast but the the
guy that jeremy no no no i don't know
chandler
tim sykes tim tim so i don't i don't
follow him but i
enjoyed his podcast yeah he made like
millions of dollars so it's nothing like
that
but i rose that money to 45 grand and i
only bought two stocks like i said a 50
chance of this really working out the
lowest i ever bought bank of america for
was four dollars and 20 cents
back in 2008. so i bought spxu
which is not a stock tip and i lost
everything i didn't know what i was
doing so i froze whenever the market
corrected and started
back up but i'll tell you this i've done
the equation a million times and it's a
learning experience anytime i ever make
a mistake i try to learn from it
if i would have bought bank of america
instead of spxu
at 18 years old to put seven thousand
bucks in it would have turned out to be
about 360 thousand dollars
if you take bank of america 45 000 been
10 700 shares
multiply that by the time uh you never
know though 100 agree yeah so that's why
this stock
time has been my super bowl so i am i'm
going to make up my losses and i still
haven't bought spx you and lost 100 000
yeah any loss like that just consider
that like a college education not to do
that again
expensive every loss that i've taken
like that what i i don't think i've
taken a loss
that i think the biggest loss i i i've
ever taken i think was i lost
not lost well i did lose 10 grand in um
gosh what was it uh dave and buster's
stock the crypto experience was not a
pleasant one for you either oh
gosh so i put uh how much
i bought like i bought like a bitcoin
back in 2017
i think i bought it like 17 something
sold it at 17.5 so i basically i was a
warren buffett i thought like i knew the
market i beat i beat bitcoin
and then i put some money in uh right
it was ryblocks back in the day at like
i forget
it's been so it's been like almost four
years now i think i bought it like a
dollar thirty or something like this or
like a dollar two dollars
and uh i put uh i don't know how many
grand it's it's been a while like five
six grand back then
and ry blocks went from like a dollar 37
all the way to like 38 oh wow and i was
sitting on like
a hefty chunk of cash and i just thought
i'm an idiot it was at 38 and i'm like
it's gonna be
traded very soon on binance and every
single coin that goes on binance
goes up like you know even more so my
plan was that like
people were saying it's probably worth
about 50 once it gets traded on binance
so i thought i was so smart i'm like i'm
gonna sell it at 44.
so is it 38 and i'm like 44 is like my
magic number and i can sell before
everyone else
and within days days later
the whole crypto market just comes
crashing down
and i'm thinking no it's gonna come back
and uh
as it started dropping then it was like
well i may as well just write it out
i wrote out the whole thing at the
bottom it was worth like
under a dollar and now it's worth about
350 4 bucks so like i'm still holding it
i haven't done a single thing
but i i could have made so much money in
the span of like a week and a half
and i just got that was his greed that
was like i was
like guaranteed all this money had i
just sold but i just wanted a little bit
more
but it was stupid that was just stupid
but that was
that was play money i basically thought
that like hey instead of putting it on
the tables i'm just gonna put it in this
so be it but uh yeah that was that would
i that was probably my biggest loss dave
and buster's was another one
uh bought in and immediately said pot
it goes down to like 11 i bought it i
think at like 17 went down to 11.
stayed there for the longest time and
then at the end of the year
i was doing tax loss harvesting i'm like
okay let me let me cut my losses on this
as soon as this will start going up and
now it's at like 36. so i would have
doubled my money
but i sold at the low point of the day
so as soon as i sold you just can't read
that stock anymore man
no well no no this this the lesson here
is
is honestly i just just for stocks just
hold don't sell never sell a stock if
you ever want to short the market
tell me first oh yeah if i buy it the
the stock will drop
at least forever oh jeez it's the way it
goes everything i bought lately has been
going up well it worries me i think how
much the market's been going up lately
because it's like
i i realize there's no way that
everything you buy
is just up like four percent the next
day that it's not sustainable you can't
keep doing that
uh green energy stocks are going nuts
and i've just i'm worried like i got to
play it safer
but it's just it's wild wild market
right now
and then you know i can't wait to see if
that's if
if or all of our worry is correct or
whenever all of the entertainment and
all of the gaming and all of the
just from cruise lines and travel when
that gets back to normal
hopefully what will happen then we going
to 40 000 for that i mean i just don't
know you could
because here's a you have you have two
things one you have these crazy
valuations
and just it they don't make sense what
things are trading at right now
but you have really low interest rates
you have an economy that's shut down
you have a lot of money pouring in
where's that money going it's all going
to the stock market so that's boosting
up prices
i think we could continue to go higher
uh or if interest rates go up maybe that
might put a damper on things
but as of now it just seems like where
else can you invest your money
it's the stock market so even though
valuations are high interest rates are
so
low maybe that kind of balances out the
other thing i was thinking is there
could be
a i've talked about this before but a uh
like a shift of money moving away from
tech
and into recovery stocks and so even
though the markets overall might be the
same just money gets taken from here
gets put over here as people try to play
the play the science but
either way it's like i'd love to look
back at this 10 years from now just see
if what we thought is accurate at all
and it's really just a guessing game
good news is from everything you've
taught everything that we all know it'll
still go up
if it doesn't yeah we got a lot more
problems than our portfolio
i think long term i think we could look
at this 10 years from now and be like
hey the market's the exact same as it
was 10 years
i mean it's definitely a chance it's a
chance but as long as i think you're
buying in every month or every week or
you're buying inconsistently you're
going to buy through the lows you're
going to buy them through the highs it's
going to average out over the long term
it's not really going to matter that
much
it's not like you're just going to
invest like everything today and that's
it for the rest of your life
put it on do i say it right dogecoin
dogecoin the doge
yeah i i watched but i didn't understand
it's treated me really well actually i'm
about a hundred percent gosh i would
have been up four hundred percent on
that investment on that that one thing i
think i sold with the next i sold it the
next day because i thought it was so
stupid but
do you remember uh when we first talked
about my portfolio just on a
on a mentorship group when i had that
stock that was at 400 something
percent what i don't remember it was
it's called uh
xspa i think i'm saying that right
because i'm mad at it
but yeah that one was at 400 i was up i
don't even know the number
um but i bought more i bought not at
that number and then now it's
losing me i lost so much money how much
are you up overall like
net on your stock portfolio well i i
guess we'll we should talk about how
much i put in
because i put in uh i've always been
very frugal i've always saved a lot of
my money and i like to buy rolexes and
things but i feel like the whole value i
just make that plug because
somebody says a watch thing but um
yeah i put in 450 000 bucks now i didn't
just put that in day one i
been i started buying i thought i was
gonna put a hundred then it kept going
low and then when it went down to
eighteen thousand i've i've got disney
at eighty seven dollars
a share i've got a lot i've got a royal
cruise line in like
80 i don't know it's very low it's
almost a 52 week high i mean 52 week low
and uh right now i'm up
uh 400 000 or so i'm up my portfolio is
955
current value however i have a hundred
and four thousand dollar loss with spx
you haven't sold it yet so
technically i'm up even more and then i
had i took
profits last year of 44 000. so i sold
just because
i sold when it went up and then i bought
back diamond hands man you got to have
the diamond hands
what does that mean oh diamond hands is
basically just diamonds oh i thought you
said diamond tans was like
diamond tans yeah i'm sorry yeah no it's
this has been a crazy year
uh i i haven't actually said this but uh
officially i'm up over a million dollars
in the stocks in the stock market last
year you're up over a million dollars
we're doing fist bumps on that one
that's crazy well it feels weird fist
bumping or then when i okay
okay yeah dude
we do something better because it's a
billion dollars yeah i'm up
nearly five thousand dollars in my robin
hood account it's awesome for this year
yeah which is pretty good kevin is the
real winner though
so everything like i could be excited
about something and he does it 20
million times better yeah
i think i think every episode we talk
about kevin let's not talk
let's just let's not talk about kevin
let's just kevin who kevin
yeah i think yeah we'll just edit it me
kevin made so many millions from tesla
stock that's
so many and uh he's he's now the
barometer of like
just yeah he's doing he's he's like
we're not talking about it but he's like
yeah but he's making it for the next
level every episode
he he could be the running like we have
an inside joke
across the back of the next yeah
he should be just like the the the gag
on the like the inside joke for the
channels
every episode there's one mention get it
get it uh meet kevin cut out
and then just like oh that would be
funny bring him on as a guest the cutout
yeah he does and he's work ethic he does
a lot of crazy
yeah yeah he's willing to put it all on
the line and that's right it's awesome
to see
but hey it doesn't have to always be
millions because i have one friend who
invested fifteen hundred bucks
they're at ten thousand they invested in
sasol stock ssl just a really good stock
and a company where the plant is where
i'm from and then kayla invested
45 she's a real estate agent that's my
fiance 45 000 and she's at
70 plus so i mean if the market goes
down you can either get scared or you
can get in
and if you get in the right things and
you're paying attention you know
it could be really great and if you're
worried by mutual fund that tracks the s
p yeah you don't have anything to worry
about yeah definitely that that's my
thing this year is i feel like i'm up
too much
so now i want to play like i really
that's amazing you shouldn't you
shouldn't it shouldn't be like
things are going up i think too fast uh
i agree with that yeah
i watched right there i didn't see that
i need i want to i want to i want to i
want to see that
yeah i fortunately have not lost money
on like anything i've done on robin hood
like it's getting ridiculous this is
what i'm talking about it's like what do
i know
like let's be honest here right i'm only
22. what what do i know i've been
investing for a while but i don't know
what i'm doing
options expert though i'm gonna learn
options from you yeah i mean i know
about them right but
at the same time i don't think that i
should be doing as well as i am
so i would say a lot of it but here's
the thing here's what makes me skeptical
is i thought in 2015
i started getting a lot more cautious
about buying real estate
uh because i felt the market is it's up
every year the market was increasing
like 12 to 15 percent
and 2015 interest rates started going up
and i'm like
that's probably gonna taper off a little
bit i began
just i was very cautious about every
deal that i bought after that because
i'm like i need to get a good deal just
in case
and since then that was like 35 percent
ago and were
you know a third higher than back then
and everything back then is now a
bargain
so it goes to show you know but we're
only like four or five
how long is 2015. six years ago six
i still wait 15 no six years ago
i still think 2015 is like three years
oh yeah i agree with you
2008 like it's only three years ago that
was only yesterday you know
right our war stories but i think i
think as long as we look at things in
ten year increments
like i think even if we look back two
years from now we're like hey everything
was
half price back then i think every 10
years is a is a good
gauge where the market's going long term
but uh well i just feel like things are
going too well
i always get yeah we could have said
that so long ago though
that's true it's difficult to time it
that's true just make sure you're paying
attention to the whole market because
the reason i lost all that money
i was trading in a recession which
basically is what you're doing
right and so you know a
an event that only happens every 100
years and so what
what happened was i knew what i knew but
i didn't know the market was like
infinitely right so that's why you know
i just you know
maybe it'll save you some money with
that with that old man tip right there
yeah thank you for that i think this
would be a good time we open these
rocket packs
i'm itching up these packs are 500 each
what we're going to be doing we each
pick two packs and we see who has the
most valuable cards
in these packs and i think there's a
good chance there's gonna be a
hollow dark charizard in here and one of
us
might get it so are we doing double or
nothing
are we gonna 600 bucks okay so i lost
300 bucks on the second channel so
that's yours
uh i don't want it i don't want to lose
600 come on graham just do it man
i'm not going to i'm not going to lose
60. you get to keep
the 300 uh i'm not gonna
i can't do it hey can't do it his
frugalness
it's proof i set a limit 300 bucks is as
much as i'm willing to lose
how about this yeah how about whoever
wins this one we all put in a hundred
dollars
more it's 400 i mean a hundred dollars
each like he's over there his face he
said we're cutting all this out of the
podcast
11
i love it because it's a 33 chance that
i'm gonna
win like i'll make this even better okay
now the cards once you open
packs yeah it is better to keep them
sealed because that is a 500 pack
or it could be a you know 70 pack
how about this all three of us that open
them well you're of course going to keep
them because you knew me and graham are
going to keep what we pull anyway
now you get to keep what you pull you
get to keep people yeah so if you pull a
charge
it's yours to use a thousand dollars
worth of packs wow
okay all right i'll agree to twenty
dollars it's within my budget
you have to open it though you can't you
can't use your sealed products yeah yeah
so
whoever pulls a charizard or the best or
the best
gifts twenty bucks sixty dollars the
other person okay and they keep their
own twenty and they
i'll divvy up these packs between us all
do the honors
all right two two and two yeah
all right let's see here this one seems
a little lighter
so you go ahead and take that one all
right buddy oh i like this one
i like that one you can feel the gram
yeah okay this one feels like you
so does that mean it's empty okay
all right here you go the graham no pun
intended there yeah
oh man this is a here you go i'll take
this one all right all right
sure you want to give me the charizard
is that what you wanted to do yeah yeah
we'll see about that
all right you want to go first uh yeah
sure i'll go first
okay
all right you just peel them down the
center and try to pull them but
sometimes it's easier to pillow you got
dark rapidash that's a good looking card
everyone
all right i'll take that you know what
you can hear the stress in his voice
okay you'll flip this track sure yeah
this works
um challenge energy
diglett ponita
magnemite dratini
rattata
[Music]
all right this is the heavy one this is
the heavy one okay
oh my gosh this is so exciting nerves in
his voice this is
so exciting so basically we're gonna
talk about return on investment
it went from 500 to like 50. yeah
dark flareon that's a cool card i like
this card i love that i wish they came
out it's one of my favorite artworks
dark persian okay dark wartortle right
goop gas attack meowth
eevee zubat oddish
grimer here we go ekans and do it slowly
oh my gosh
[Music]
is that though no no it's the number at
the bottom if it's a no it's not a five
so
that is an error chord now once again
we're talking about first edition here
you take your card down
i don't want a bender that's a good one
it's an amazing chord fortunately it's
not if that were a holo
that would be one of the best cards that
is the second best card period yeah so
basically when i pulled
the dark charizard the the dark
dragonite's just as cool but if you get
the
five and it's holographic and it's first
edition they're selling for like twenty
thousand thirty it's
nuts it's so nuts okay so my next this
is crazy you go next
the final touches to the to the last one
i got to get the i got to get its
brother dragon it was great though that
was a good
amazing card of all the non-hollows you
could hold that was one of the top ones
so we got an energy got a dark flareon
trainer ponyta drowzee
coughing uh ratata right ratata
we got a trainer we got meowth we got
evie
oh my no you pulled it
wow that is gorgeous it's a five
one of my favorites wow yes so so here's
the here's the thing so while we have it
on camera
in the event that it was non-holographic
and a five
that's the because it's an error just
like money and coins and everything else
just
wow uh here i'll grab you
oh my gosh that is gorgeous i was like
yeah i want to sleep for this this one
oh geez it's very nice wow
dragonite's one of my absolute favorite
pokemon dad is amazing
she's pretty swirl on it the swirl is
yeah yeah
oh jeez all right you win
we still can have a charizard because
dragonite's great but charizard's better
my trash talks need some work yeah we'll
see about this oh man
dark primate trainer
dark cadabra trainer abra snake
duck oh charmander machop
slowpoke and it's blue hey
dark gyarados
so i am not upset about this at all not
upset
wow that is a beautiful cord what
why did i give you those packs thank you
thank you jack
man these packs are sponsored by jack
shelby thank you oh my gosh
two hollows all right now graham's
coming in with a
big kahuna well we haven't pulled a dark
jar so if there was going to be one
graham you have it remember so we got we
got a digger
garbage run cadabra sleep
diglett drowsy dratini ponita
magnemite meowth this is
non-holo here comes team rocket but your
last pack
it's crazy the last one we haven't
gotten to charizard yet
talk about a nail biter dude right e2
emporion
dark charmeleon good sign dark dragon
air ponita
rattata coughing meowth trainer
zubat evie it's green
all right we've got a base set pack from
graham now so this is something i've
been holding on to
for months now i bought this one pack
it's almost a thousand dollars to this
pack it's a base set
i've been waiting to open i've just been
waiting for the right opportunity to
open this up
this is unweighed have no idea what's in
it
uh let's give it a shot this is i'm
actually really nervous on this one okay
so we got maintenance kakuna
super portion duo
experience no not really i'm
i'm just trying to be optimistic you
know what that was fun for me
oh that was so awful i tell you what i
think now is a good time to give him his
present
his gift my gosh so i i gave you a
crappy gift i'm so sorry because you
didn't pull out no that's all right but
i mean that's still cool keep your
packards like it's
it's absolutely don't throw those away
it's they're going to be worth money all
right
so oh we didn't talk about the watches
but that's okay with me
we can he's
gonna give him a moment he's not happy
i'm i'm upset right now
let's give grandma space he's going
through it
i hurt for you though got a ten thousand
dollar broken box i just
i gave you the dragonite and the
gyarados dude you're an amazing friend
yeah and i said friend earlier i the
friendship has been that much yeah
yeah but remember when i gave you two
options to have i don't i can't make
that anymore oh
that dragon let me look at that for a
second well you know what i'll look at
it later it's a podcast well
uh i had a good time on these pack pools
so uh too
soon okay i'm sorry i can say that
because
here it's really neat all right let's
see let's see graham's gift would you
like me to hold that
should i try to figure out i i used to
do this this feels like christmas like i
always just to feel it
yeah i have no idea what it is i mean it
should be a heavy basic pack right about
now but
first edition heavy face shoot shadow i
mean goodness
the only way it would be i could afford
the uh the like the the spanish version
all right oh someone got you the rolex
might as well have the rolex of pens
so this is wow these these are
incredible pens
i've seen legitimately there are youtube
channels that review pens like this
can't come to a housewarming party
without a i know it's not that what it's
this is but now it is housewarming party
and then bring you a pot be afraid to
use this pen
sign a big check or like a you know all
jacks checks sign all jacks
or your your next big angel investment
that would be your special pin
that makes sense yeah yeah look how
fancy this
is i and i keep the boxes and the casing
to them
i don't know if they're collectible or
not but rolex boxes are expensive
just the box by itself oh it's upside
down boom
and it matches your watch these are
incredible look at the tip of this
oh my gosh thank you man so yeah that
was fun
jeez that's insane thank you this has
been a unique podcast episode so far
yeah it's like oprah you get packs you
get a pen stuff
yeah you get a dragonite you get a
character you get a dragonite all right
so you've also showed up with uh
another thing that's pretty exciting
your watch collection
just a few of my favorite watches that i
have this was my
absolute first watch uh i've ever
purchased
of course uh as you just saw i blinked
it out
and uh i bought it for 4 500 now not the
bezel
the bezel cost me let's call it six but
it was it was in like
20 14 15 so it's been a long time this
one i brought because i knew you'd like
it
uh this is the batman the batman
and you got the jubilee dialogue i love
that
yep um never been worn so i'm gonna put
that back on there but yeah
these are rolex are good investments and
i'll show you real quick on why
this watch retails for ninety seven
hundred dollars uh my
jeweler not the other guy but my friend
that i actually linked those two
together
his profits went up but what happened is
he said i'm the only person that he
knows that would buy this for not retail
so i paid about a grand under that for
batman and it retails for like fifteen
thousand yeah so
you doubled your money in that
absolutely and so i didn't want to sell
it
and then of course i have my rose gold
daytona i had a i love that yeah
i had a stainless steel panda which is
something like 26 000 right now in the
market 20 000 but my my diamond dealer
needed it and
he took it from me so he bought it for
me for cost when you wear watches like
that do people notice it
and do they like point it out the shiny
diamond one so i don't wear it
unless i'm going like no somewhere else
this has got to attract this or the
daytona has to attract way more
attention through the blinged out so
let's call it a qualified buyer it would
track somebody that knows what they're
looking at
if somebody saw this watch they're like
hey man that's really cool how much for
it like
50 bucks they don't they don't know it's
fully gold
but the diamond thing shiny and they
know what diamonds what do they say to
you when they when they
know what it is they say geez man when
you gamble with a shiny watch
people come sit by you and start talking
to you you know uh
yeah more more with the the diamonds
than this
because immediately if i see an iced out
watch
immediately my first go-to impression is
unless it's like
sometimes you could look at the person
you're like oh you know that's real a
lot of the times i just think it's fake
that that's probably but if i see this
and i open that up for me
i said you nice on that one for me i
would just i would just think it's fake
like that's my
go-to because there's it's so easy just
yeah
just to yeah i faked that yeah you know
what should jack get i've been telling
jack to get it i'm not going to buy a
watch
graham wants me to buy a watch about it
the last time like
i'm about it but it's just like it's so
much money dude
i i think jack could pick up a good
submariner at like 65.
remember when we talked when we talked
about this originally
since then it's probably gone up like a
thousand dollars in value
i'll i'll give you an example um so
the watch i just showed you with the the
shiny bezel with that shiny bezel it's
like a 17 000 watch retail
but maybe less maybe 15 but not much
less than that
i bought that watch for 4 500 bucks
without the bezel somebody offered me 11
to take my diamond bezel off and put the
original because i've got to keep the
original bezel
and i would have been able to double
money on the watch so and that was six
years ago yep
so i got a question when you initially
started out selling cars
you said that you averaged you know
seventy five thousand dollars each year
when you were
doing that full time um your first year
how much did you make
my for oh so my first year uh when 2008
happened yeah i made 59 000. so that was
your first year full time selling cars
my first no so that was about eight
months eight months selling costs fifty
nine thousand dollars so about seven i
started
and then of course the year but my first
full year
uh the following year was 75. and can
you talk about like commissions and
stuff like that and what kind of cars
you were selling
sure uh basically any dealership but for
anybody that's watching i don't want i
don't want to talk too many details
about my store
but you know the any dealership out
there is going to pay you about 25
commissions on the front side 10 on the
back
uh which is just f and i income things
like that and they pay you bonuses and
we we we pay our sales people extremely
well
uh because you know like like me and
graham with the rolex or
giving you two packs you know it's it's
not always about the bottom line
sometimes it's just about being you know
when people think it's weird like what
are you doing that for
i just cuz so you know we really take
care of our staff because we feel like
it's not the barn it's the horses and
the people make the difference
so you want to you know treat them right
so they'll stay that's smart and what
kind of cars
does your dealership sell we have two
chevy stores honda hyundai
cadillac nissan
we have i said honda we have a dodge
chrysler jeep ram and gmc
i think that might be 11 because there's
two chevy stores anybody's counting
wow what do you drive i drive a dodge
ram we just bought that franchise
and it's pretty cool to we've always you
know it's when you don't sell it it's
like
oh like the rival yeah real estate
agency like don't go see them
not that that's how you would sell it
but still and then now i drive it
drives great you know i think it's
amazing truck and the screen is huge
and would you say you have expensive
taste i will not buy anything
that doesn't make sense so i don't know
the answer to that question yeah
no food yeah because crawfish are
expensive where i'm from
because crawfish are like 7.99 a pound
y'all need to have that so it's amazing
well how about this we could we could
end it here
sure but do the gambling and we'll eat
gamble we'll come back and we'll see
what it's
absolutely all right so segwit i'm gonna
snap my fingers
and when i snap we're gonna reappear
here after
some nice dining and some gambling and
we'll tell you guys how we did all right
still wearing my avocado oh he's got
some avocado socks these are lucky okay
things are gonna go in our direction
we're already
we're done 320. we have 20. i'm down 20
bucks you're up 320
all right every 40 actually and we'll
see how the gambling pans out
right all right so thank you grant for
treating us to some dinner
yeah this is the iced coffee midnight
hour
yeah midnight edition it's like what 1
20 in the morning right now something
like that so
after the podcast we went to dinner
thank you
so much for dinner so good and then we
went to red rock casino
where jack and uh grant and i
uh partaked in some gambling good times
i was uh super against it but they
convinced me
and i won 99 and 50 cents off of my
100 so the way i looked at it he won
and 105 dollars and then made a five
dollar charitable i did make a
donation to the tip so right the the
real estate agent and car salesman
ganged up on jack
yeah it was a good night thank you guys
for the peer pressure i
really appreciate it how many blackjacks
did you hit i got two blackjacks and
they gave me uh
two uh really cool coins for each
blackjack so i got those fifty seven
pieces
yeah he's like those things yeah there's
silver dollars
i don't know but that was exciting you
guys won some pretty good money huh yeah
i was up i think 300 and something uh
and that's after the tip yep and you're
up 300 and something too yep hashtag
after the dip yeah
is that that sounds pretty good
like i like it yeah well uh that was
pretty exciting also another thing to
note
was at dinner interestingly enough as we
were about to leave
uh the waitress came over and she gave
us like some
some din some dessert that was on the
house she said that the uh like the
pastry chef
recognized graham so they gave us a
really cool
if you're watching thank you so much
thank you really appreciate that that
meant uh
that's a lot i don't know if you're
gonna be watching the iced coffee hour
all the way to the very end but it was
very tasty it was delicious
so if you're watching this thank you so
much and comment down below if you're
watching this yeah
and the coffee just gave just enough of
a boost to go and
get going yeah yeah so successful night
thank you so much we had a blast so we
just got we got to keep doing this every
month
damn cool yep all righty so
with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching we should use the
other outro
okay it just just goes yeah let's cut to
the other outro right now
so grant thank you so much for coming on
thank you for the pokemon cards thank
you for the pen
uh guys if you want to subscribe i'll
put your channel down below in the
description
and go and check out the gram stefan
show because this is where we do the
pack battle
and we see who pulled the better pokemon
card so if you want to go watch that
uh actually this is gonna post first so
you don't know
who won that so guys thank you so much
for watching i really appreciate it as
always make sure to destroy the like
button subscribe button
and notification bell also feel free to
add us on instagram i posted pretty much
daily so if you want to add us there
feel free to add us there
and don't forget get your four free
stocks down below in the description
from weeble those stocks are worth all
the way up to 1
600 so you may as well it's free money
so if you if if you don't like free
money then don't do it but if you like
free money the link is down below in the
description thank you guys so much for
watching
and until next time welcome back to the
36th
ever iced coffee hour where we have art
we i'm sorry yeah with us
we yeah welcome back to the 36th
ever iced coffee hour where the channel
has already made 36
714 dollars since y'all started it
thanks so much for coming on grant it's
amazing meeting you
let's do the intro once more and save
like hey my name is grant navarro oh
forgotten people yeah yeah
yeah it was good go for it no very few
people ever get it right on the first
try yeah go for it
and i've watched this like seven times
to try to get it yeah
all right go
just making sure i got it right again so
hey everybody welcome back to the 36
there okay
hey everybody welcome back to the 36th
ever iced coffee hour where
the channel has already made thirty
seven thousand
thirty six seven i messed it up thirty
four i was giving you anything yeah
there you go thirty four seven fourteen
yup all right